Coffee on a Tuesday and blog 21.
So I have this thing about bookstores
whenever I walked by them.
It's sort of like,
you know how in Vegas they pump scented
air through the casinos to make the
gamblers feel good.
Well,
whenever I walked by a bookstore,
I get the smell of books in my face and
I just have to go in and I could spend
all day in there.
The reason I usually leave is because I
start to get light headed and realize
that I'd miss lunch and it's coming up
on dinner and people are expecting me
and I have to do this thing and write
that email and move on with my day.
And maybe it's not smart for one to
analyze the charm of bookstores.
But.
Well,
I've already sort of started it and
anyway,
I read this article in the Times
yesterday and and it's got me thinking
about it.
See the article said that Barnes and
noble has predicted that in the coming
year it will lose more money than even
Wall Street had predicted it would.
And this after the bankruptcy and
disillusion of borders,
its main competitor is the specter of
ebooks with Amazon and it's kindle as a
dominant force,
threatens to diminish this,
this last chain of booksellers,
and if they do,
you might be left buying your your best
sellers at places like target or
Walmart.
And it's ironic because it was barnes
and noble,
which drove so many independent
booksellers to bankruptcy,
sort of like what Tom Hanks does to Meg
Ryan and you've got mail
with his multilevel,
homogenize the world Mochaccino land.
Now
mochaccino land might be the last best
hope for print books and publishers like
penguin and Random House and Simon and
Schuster who used that front of the
store display table to premier new
talent to push the next big thing at
table,
which is especially important for new
writers like me now to fight off the
kindle.
Barnes and noble has the nook and it has
boosted some revenue to the company
though it's hard to fight off both
Amazon and apple at the same time.
David had enough trouble fighting just
the one goliath.
William Lynch,
the new CEO of Barnes and noble has done
everything he possibly can to stay
relevant and ahead of the curve,
but his company is worth this much while
Amazon's is worth this much and I guess
we'll see how it plays out,
but I pause to wonder if there is
something lost by the digitizing of
books in the possible end of bookstores.
It's safe to say that someone reading a
book on their kindle or Nook is having
an experience which is negligibly
different from reading a paper book.
The story is still there.
The words arrange as they are still
produced,
the same magic,
the same music of mental images that
only pros can make that won't be lost.
I guess what I fear is not the death of
stories,
but rather the end of the physical
space,
which those stories take up walking
through the stacks and shelves of the
bookstore.
All our past and present knowledge looms
cast shadows on you and maybe you get
more accurate of sense with all that
papered space of the distance.
We've come as a thinking rice.
It's like a real living interactive
timeline.
It's not the same with a selection of
ebooks on your ipad.
It's no space,
they're just scrolling.
You can't see each and every page tight
against the next and you can't see the
overstock or the display table or the
books people have taken out of their
shells but decided not to buy.
So there's a million variables in the
bookstore variable stretched over space
and time,
and it's true that sometimes a book like
a magic rain can find you
and maybe there's an alchemy in that,
which would be a shame to lose.
Or maybe I'm just being sentimental.
The amount Susanna.